hey guys it's justine and the 2021 apple
event just ended and of course there's a
bunch of new and awesome updates but
first
i got a chance to chat with tim cook
right after the event ended so i'm so
excited for you guys to check that out
i'll put a link in the description if
you want to watch that after this video
we talked about the new cinematic mode
in the iphone 13 the new ipad the new
apple watch 7 apple fitness plus
honestly this was such a dream come true
so
i'm still so excited
hello how are you i'm doing well how are
you really good good to see you again oh
my gosh youtube thanks so much for
joining this this fun little interview
here right after the event okay so first
up let's actually talk about the event
itself if you guys watched it this kind
of felt like a paired down version of
some of the last apple events because
the last ones have been like these crazy
over-the-top elaborate productions which
is amazing but this one felt a little
bit more like the old school live events
that we're used to like the ones that
were actually live and on stage i do
really hope that one day we can return
to apple campus again because it was
seriously so much fun getting a chance
to actually go there and really
experiencing all of that in person i
also loved all of the amazing
fly-throughs that they did through
california even though i live here just
kind of getting that overview was really
awesome now let's get into the actual
announcements they started off by giving
us a preview of apple tv plus their fall
lineup of tv shows now i'm so excited
about the morning show the second season
because the first season was honestly
one of my most favorite shows ever jon
stewart is also coming back to tv i
think that's something that a lot of
people were not expecting so that's
super exciting and they also announced
updates to the ipad and a huge update to
the ipad mini we also got a look at the
new apple watch series seven it has an
all new design well i guess like not all
entirely new it's kind of like an
updated refresh there's also some
updates to fitness plus and of course
the brand new iphone 13 iphone 13 mini
iphone 13 pro and iphone 13 pro max can
we get a little round of applause here
just let's hear it let's hear it for the
iphones
i really hope tyler puts in a sound
effect here or everything i'm doing
right now is just weird so they updated
the ipad it's got the same design that
we're used to but now with way better
performance thanks to the a13 bionic
chip can we get another round of
applause for a13 let's hear it you'll
have that all day battery life and it
has a new 12 megapixel ultra wide front
camera with center stage for video calls
and now it also supports other
accessories like the smart keyboard and
the first gen apple pencil and it starts
at only 3 29. now what i'm really
excited about though as i mentioned at
the end of this video is the updates to
the ipad mini and it's been a while
since this thing actually got a real
refresh but honestly this seems like so
much more than a refresh like this seems
like a whole new ipad it has apple's new
liquid retina display and now with some
really thin bezels just like the ipad
air and ipad pro which is so nice
especially on such a small device like
this it's also getting a massive boost
in performance there's upgrades for the
camera on the front and back usbc
connectivity hold up a second did you
guys hear that correctly yes the ipad
mini has usbc it also my friends has
touch id on the power button
these are the things that i want in my
iphone so badly this is actually pretty
exciting if you kind of think about it
because this is slowly integrating us
into maybe iphone 14 either not having a
port at all or it'll finally be usbc
powered so the ipad mini does come in
four new colors there's a pink a star
light a purple and a space gray there's
also some new folio covers to match and
this little thing now supports the
second gen apple pencil which is amazing
they've packed so much into this little
ipad including 5g support and the price
is gonna be starting at 4.99 i actually
cannot wait to test out the ipad mini
just because the form factor is so
small but yet it's like a larger iphone
but i feel like it is something that has
been desperately needing an upgrade so
i'm so excited to try it out will i get
the pink one yeah i mean of course like
was that even a question like what so
next up is the apple watch series seven
you guys know that aside from my love
and obsession for my iphone the apple
watch is probably one of my favorite
products not just an apple product but
product in general i love this thing so
much it's honestly really kind of
changed my life in the way that i
approach fitness because it's really
helped me quantify my fitness and
actually see changes as i'm progressing
through my fitness so i'm always very
excited to see what the next version is
going to bring this one is more focusing
on some design upgrades it has an
always-on retina display with 20 more
screen area than the series 6. it's got
a thinner border which is going to allow
for some really awesome ui changes to
give you more space for content on the
watch face there's even going to be a
full keyboard in the apple watch now
let's just think about that you have a
full keyboard right here on your wrist
in addition to the design updates
there's also new support for cycling and
bike fall detection i actually started
riding a bike a lot more over the last
few years so i'm very excited to test
this out it's got some enhanced dust and
water resistance now and stronger crack
resistant front crystal it comes in some
new aluminum case finishes there's a
midnight starlight a green a new blue
and a product red pricing is starting at
3.99 and will ship in the fall i have a
question
when is fall like is this early fall
like what is the first day of us it's
like what are we talking here are we
talking like spooky season when is fall
fall begins on september 22nd and ends
december 20th
like are we talking early fall
so along with the new apple watch we
also got some really fun updates to
apple fitness plus and i am such a huge
fan of apple fitness plus so this is
really great they've got some new
workouts for pilates and mindfulness so
you'll be able to do the meditation
classes as audio only on your apple
watch which is really nice if you don't
want to have your ipad or have some sort
of distraction you can just listen to
the audio right on your wrist there's
also something new called workout
programs basically these programs are
designed to get you ready for a specific
activity the example they showed was
winter sports and skiing but i can
imagine that these programs can be for
people training like a marathon or maybe
like some bike races or maybe
even something like sport specific like
some workouts to enhance my jujitsu or
maybe to enhance my lightsaber training
perhaps i don't know just a thought the
other thing that they announced is
actually really cool this is a new group
fitness workout feature and it's powered
by share play so you and your friends
can basically do workouts and hang out
together you can have up to 32 people in
a group and honestly like i'm really
hoping that i can get 32 of my tech
youtuber friends to do a group fitness
class together but i'm curious like who
would you want to see and what class
would you like us to do leave it in the
comments below and finally of course
apple has announced the brand new iphone
13 13 mini 13 pro and 13 pro max so the
iphone 13 and the iphone 13 mini is
going to have a new sleek design with
some flat edges and apple's super retina
xtr display and they come in five new
colors we've got the pink blue midnight
starlight and the product red now uh i
do kind of wish that the pink was like a
super hot pink color but this is
something that i've been waiting for for
a really really long time like i wanted
a pink iphone and here it is pink pink
iphone so both the 13 and the 13 mini
share the same dual camera system with a
new wide camera and this new feature
called cinematic mode they showed this
short film that was shot entirely in
this mode and it was so cool because it
basically lets you rack focus track
subjects with focus and it will
automatically detect faces using
algorithms and machine learning it's
actually really really cool you guys
know that i love my iphone accessories
there are some new mag safe cases in
matching colors and there's now even a
new magsafe leather wallet with built-in
find my i recently had my wallet stolen
and uh it's funny though because you
would think that justine who was so
excited about these air tags would have
had an air tag in her wallet or even her
bag that was taken did she
no she
did not the crazy thing is i was
actually using a backpack that i don't
normally use because it was one that i
really didn't care about as much because
i was hiking and i just thought for
whatever reason let's just throw that in
the backseat don't care
it was stolen it's also kind of funny
because i actually tweeted something
about losing my air pods as well and i
thought it'd be really cool if the new
air pods would have find my integrated
into them but even though we didn't get
any new airpods at this event the find
my wallet will suffice it's actually
pretty excited about that so the iphone
13 pro and the 13 pro max also got some
incredible upgrades especially in the
display and the camera system they have
an all new super retina xdr display with
pro motion enabling adaptive refresh
rate up to 120 hertz now i love this so
much on the ipad so i'm so happy that
apple is finally bringing 120 hertz
promotion to their phones now what's
great is they both have identical camera
features now all three rear cameras have
gotten huge upgrades in addition to the
cinematic mode we already talked about
the ultra wide camera can now do macro
photos the zoom lens is now upgraded to
a 3x telephoto as opposed to the two and
a half on the iphone 12 pro max oh and
this is also super exciting they said
that later on we're gonna be able to
capture and edit video in pro res this
is awesome especially if you're a final
cut editor that is something that we
love speaking of editing and shooting a
lot of content the new 13 pro phones
will have storage options of up to
one terabyte man when they announced
this i was like yes finally i've
actually filled up the storage in my 512
gig phone so this is honestly something
that i was looking forward to i do store
a lot of content in the cloud but the
thing is when i'm shooting some of these
4k videos and then editing them down a
lot of times i'm air dropping them from
my computer like the final edited piece
to my phone and a lot of times these are
really big files so it's really great to
be able to have that additional storage
just in case you need it there's usually
so much to talk about in these new
phones so i'm going to be doing a whole
separate video digging into all of the
specs all of the new upgrades and some
of the things that i wish that they had
done so be sure to keep an eye out for
that and it might actually already be
out so check the link in the description
and see if there's a link there well
that's it guys thank you so much for
watching i will have a ton more apple
content for you so don't forget to
subscribe so you won't miss the videos
be sure to hit the bell so you'll be
notified when those videos go live and
like this video and leave me some
comments below and let me know what you
would like me to test out when i
actually do get the phones in hand i'll
see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]
you